is over Lakers Furious they thought he
was fouled
excuse me and it's now overtime
LeBron James so upset
regulation is over we go to the
five-minute OT
ay
Patrick Beverly comes out on the floor
to Eric Lewis with a camera I mean just
ridiculous
and Eric Lewis rightfully tees him up
you said they thought he was fouled he
was fouled and I would you say missing
that
12 here look he tossed it to the ref on
a bit oh come on come on now and a
whistle
going the other way what happened
Steph Curry
the Steph Curry been ejected
[Applause]
wow
Steph Curry has been ejected
[Applause]
what's interesting about that I don't
think that was in reaction to anything
that happened with the official on that
offensive rebound
he was yelling at Jordan Poole to pass
him the ball
so you see the shot by Poole and Steph
is clapping for the ball
[Music]
head forward number five precious
formed back late here's what happened
well after the score you see the uh
Timberwolves throw the ball just to Russ
and they end up throwing it back and
forth to one another that's the
playground right there
Jimmy you shared with us on social media
your new hairdo as an athlete that has a
lot of hair I know that can affect your
performance what do you think your new
hair doing your dreads and extensions
are going to do for your look and how
you are performing on the court I don't
have any extensions I don't know
I don't know
uh it's still up to debate if I'm gonna
keep my hair like this or not they're
not extensions so
who knows I'm trying out a lot of new
looks y'all like my baby face assassin
look it's kind of cute isn't it second
quarter
past stolen by Drummond two on one a
little you're a step oh that's a travel
for some type of violation they're
shooting again
[Applause]
not happy about it yeah because he's
counting out how long it's taking
Giannis to to shoot
a clear Sail
[Music]
and we got to stop at your play
no you're absolutely right
[Applause]
oh Hardin was sitting on the on the
bench that's why the ball got deflected
Hardin was on the bench I only asked him
I said have you ever been in this
situation before
because it's not easy you know when you
when you have to make the free throw
that's not an easy situation to be in
because it's
the whole game doesn't come down to one
possession you know it's a lot of things
that happen but in a way you know you're
looking at it like this is a chance to
tie the game
so I just asked him like I just wanted
him to think about it a little bit like
you know have you ever been in this
situation
and he ignored me
and when he ignored me I was like you
know I'm pretty sure he thinking about
it like these these big free throws
[Applause]
every night in the NBA man I'm telling
you
yeah
what a story Grant Williams Ken Wright
oh now he has to hit it
doesn't go and neither does the tap one
of those Thera guns onto the court
smashed onto the court check this out
coming
from the left side here
over the
Miami pens yikes
through that he's ejected from this game
so
I have no idea good idea there probably
had a layup kick it out for a
three-point shot open Corner high
percentage goes right back to lamelo
nice job sticking with it and John just
wants a blow here
it's been a lot of running back and
forth and you can do this the ball
hasn't been touched he theoretically
could do this until midnight tonight I
mean we've seen a lot of basketball I
don't think I've seen this
gets it in it's going to be DeRozan to
try to win it air ball stick back is
good at the buzzer in Chicago wins it
oh my goodness
resets back out to Green on Edwards has
it stolen
Edwards
steal and score
[Applause]
bounces off of Isaiah Joe
play on
oh and that careless pass on the floor
going at it with herb Jones and I think
Steve Kerr and sitting here
that's smart coaching right there not
afford to lose him he wants to stay out
there talking but Steve Kerr needs him
he knows Draymond Green he's going to
sit him down and on the other end how
would you rate your defense tonight
you tell me man
tell something about you what how would
you rate my defense tonight be honest
there's no wrong answers be minus I can
accept that
Pig 12 only shooting 46 at the line so
far as a rookie
[Applause]
[Music]
he's too small he's too small
he's smiling at LeBron the whole time
the Lakers talk about it themselves 280
and do something yeah maybe he actually
knows it there's a linen by Reeves oh
and he does the too small
whoa revenge is sweet for the Lakers in
Austin
against Pat Ben goes up over the top and
this is
surprise you at all I think it surprised
a lot of people and then a left-handed
jump hook from a point guard
lost it plumbingly there to save the day
what do you got it makes it
the best
Cruz was going to take this shot and
then I want you to watch him
you know he's messing you know he's
messing around with his guys on the
bench and that thing came right back to
where he was
to really look for those twos and
attacking what is going on uh now this
decided not to guard their own basket
this is the Warriors Basket in the
second half there's no Maverick
Defenders Looney's like hey thank you
very much this is I've never seen this
in my life
welcome to Shaq in the fool
they were all lined up to defend on the
wrong side which is just two starters
left up here
LeBron
you guys already know with my last pick
I'm going with Mr triple double himself
right here Nicola
joking
Curry look at the shop by Bridges catch
guy running at you to contest
he played right look at all the green
and black jerseys as he drives collapses
on the king
and he finds one of his core gestures in
the corner
and Dennis Schroeder
ice water in the veins into another
offensive offensive rebound but also
leaving the ball in marantan Baseline
Stephens like I'm gonna get to this Rim
if it's the last thing did I do
well wait look he's chirping look he's
talking to him he can't he can't guard
me I'm too strong we talk about anybody
in the game
good players make themselves good great
players make everybody good and it seems
like he's taking that step right now you
know he's 24 years old but he's he's
figured out and maybe going to the
finals
pulls up nothing but the bottom of the
sack well I think we I think we were
shooting uh
I think we were shooting 20 and today we
shot 26 so we got better
at the crypto.com arena Dylan Brooks was
having words with Shannon Sharp Hall of
Famer on broadcast
[Music]
and you see Stephen Adams comes over
to protect this guy along with The
Supporting Cast and then
Shannon sharp still talking and team
Event John Moran's dad comes over had an
opportunity to talk to team around and
he said my blood pressure didn't go up a
bit nothing but love and respect for
Shannon Sharp
it's a bunch of guys
talking a bunch of trash
sit on this stage trying to but these
are professional shooter these are guys
that's all they do oh boy
I don't know if you want to see this
that hurts yeah explain it to him now
it's okay hey I'm all strong that's the
All-Star Game
come on I came out with the Dugout
okay Kate don't think it's okay
well there's no doubt
[Applause]
no doubt they actually played in the
play-in two years ago
we'll wrap up this 43rd victory for the
Grizzlies in a moment get you ready for
Grizzlies live post game that is next
do more free throws for the Warriors but
because of that
physical defense it wears you down it
gets into your legs but what it also
does is it makes you try to do a little
bit more and with that doing a little
bit more
it gets you out of your Rhythm and I
thought that Dylan did a great job of
getting them out of their Rhythm meaning
Steph Curry
[Applause]
squares out
back out to him beat on the pick and pop
lines up the seams has all day and
drills it Wheels in and scores it more
of that
and jokic
[Applause]
going back to their Championship with
Raptors 905 several years ago that
is the daughter
of DeMar DeRozan
and here's the voice you're hearing when
Raptors shoot she's screaming
[Applause]
that time it didn't work
hey it's the thought that counts trying
to get to an open spot if you're Kings
player the three ball will be available
to capitalize that time
Brown curling here he comes left hand no
jokic couple of tries misses gets it
back missed again
50 is going to be our goal 50. we're
going to hold we're holding Luke under
50.
calmly sinks that one for Point number
50. congratulations already and when I
heard that he had a foot injury I was
sad and we didn't know if he was
traveling with the team to this game or
not and then when he ended up sitting
down here I'm not that as tall as him
obviously so I could only see like his
shoes and then I look up and I see
LeBron James and early in the third for
Minnesota they'll bear fast flashes to
the free throw line effort
[Applause]
here's Gordon and kaminga fouls him all
they're going to say offensive foul on
Gordon falsely turnover well they're
running a play to try to get
Thompson down to the corner the old
Hammer play with a back screen on the
week seven skyborn and how about the
look here
yeah yeah I know it said seconds left in
regulation
young had nowhere to throw a boy through
it right into the groin
looks like smart is okay
and again he throws it off Smart
DeAndre Hunter will be the inbounder
he works deep in their corner
throws it off of four for a key that's
three straight times
blocked by Davis picked up by Schroeder
who saves it to hachimura James ahead of
the back goes up
oh he's lost control and the crowd
Delights in that
I can't ever remember seeing that from
him
just slipped out of his hands free throw
Steph Curry called a timeout here and
they didn't have any left
and a pained expression
etched across the countenance of Steve
Kerr Connor the Grizzlies is involved in
the wave as it gets around the bench all
those things here they go
look at this
this has about the exact same question
but I'm curious for you do you view this
season as a failure
uh
he was having words with Jimmy Butler on
the way down
here's the dish by Brown and here's the
shot mate by Williams and look at the
words
already Williams and Jimmy Butler is
smiling about it and then here's the
contact at the ensuing play
and let's go head to head guys
thank you Jimmy Butler Moon walks back
to half court what does he do
and now you are an NBA champion Nicola
how does that feel it's good it's good
the job is down we can go home now
congratulations like some of those
turnovers so they weren't playing at a
high efficiency level and if you're
looking forward to a parade coming up in
Denver
minutes parade
Venice parade Thursday
no
I need to go home okay
uh